Reggie Miller's a hall-of-famer he'll be
on the call for Sixers in the box that's
Thursday night at 8:00 Eastern with
Kevin Harlan and Kristen Ledlow reg
joins us now did you watch the Super
Bowl reg of course who did where did you
watch here in Calabasas on my couch with
my remote by yourself by myself
mama bear took the kids out to dojo boom
it's a trampoline place and she was like
enjoy I was like will were you rooting
for anybody um I mean obviously growing
up in California I was the biggest as
you know Joe Montana fan you know a good
friend Mark Jackson Dan Marino so I had
a little bit you know for the 49ers did
you ever meet Jill Montana I have never
met Joe Montana no my hands were
probably shaking really I just saw in
the other night I forgot you know when I
see Joe I just say hey Joe like Joe is
so unassuming we just go on you have it
like that with him I mean you're you
guys are cool like that I have his
number we're gonna have to do a meet and
greet on the show come on now all right
I'll see what I can do you know you can
do Joe's coming Joe is kind of shine
okay is there another athlete you
haven't met where you'd actually be
nervous meeting let me think about that
like Michael Jordan
[Laughter]
[Music]
again number 23 all right you got bucks
at the pelicans tonight what do you
expect out of this matchup showdown well
number one you and I for the last month
we thought that they should sit is ion
correct yeah then I'm out let him heal
up let him lose a little weight but
young man is look fantastic yes I think
we need to say that that he's look great
how would you describe his game if
somebody hadn't seen him play in the NBA
his pro game dynamic electrifying
because you see a guy at his size
because he's not the biggest guys again
I'm taller than he is but the strength
and the power and the grace that he
plays with if you look at some of the
highlights some of this missed shots was
probably his best offense because he is
such a quick leaper he rebounds his own
misses for putbacks
so I would say he the power and the
grace he's just electrifying to watch
especially when he gets into the open
court he doesn't have a go-to move yet
not yet but again he's only what 19 20
years old so I think that has time
there's a lot of players
there's MVPs I don't have go-to moves in
our game so I mean that will come in
time I was also you know there's a
couple other storylines here obviously
with the trade deadline I don't know
which team needs to make a move I would
say the Lakers in Philadelphia need to
tinker their lineups not a major move
but both of those teams in my opinion
need more shooting better shooting more
consistent shooting I think Boston needs
size especially the longer they go in
the playoffs I think Milwaukee stays Pat
I'm confused with the capela saying and
with Houston I know they like to play
small ball but as much as James Harden
and Russell West
Brook penetrate and drive they are
always collapsing the defense and a lot
of times it's that value to capella easy
office yeah so getting rid of him is a
little bit of a head-scratcher I know
they want to play six seven six six guys
but I I don't know how far'd how look
we've seen this movie in the playoffs
with the Houston right when they play
small ball so we've seen this before
it's just a little head scratcher them
trying to move capella I'm trying to
think though if there's anybody else you
know are the pelicans they somebody said
JJ Redick drew Holliday could be guys
that could be available if the pelicans
want to ask you guys that could help
championship contending teams I think
you put Holliday possibly I thought it
was a dramatic pause apparently I don't
know what's going on Reggie always has a
good phone line see a cell phone guy or
hard line guy I think Reggie's back you
had that dramatic pause they're real we
are having 40 or 50 mile an hour winds
here in SoCal so that could be subpoena
power I am on a hard line I'm not on a
cell okay I am on a hard line I do
apologize are you in the neighborhood
with the Kardashians okay who are you
who's in your neighborhood
no one no one infamous is in my
neighborhood how about somebody who's
famous so the Kardashians are a couple
blocks over or a subdivision over that's
a good character ation there I can kind
of see where kind of see with their plot
of land there's Brad Pitt live by you I
didn't know Brad Pitt was a Calabasas
guy I don't know I just made it up I
knew some kgs out here the Kardashians
are there's a whole bunch of people out
here but I'd ever see anyone truthfully
like when you go to the
store I don't owe you don't go to the
store I go to the store I do all the
shopping for the house I just don't see
really do see me I go a lot of times
though you know I'm a day shopper
morning shopper just driven later
they're going in the evening just Drake
live there
I heard Drake lives in Calabasas never
seen Amy quacks lives out this way never
seen it well plus they those people have
like big houses in big plots of land so
you wouldn't see have you ever started
this not have you ever shot in Calabasas
like in like a local park have you ever
shot hoops I have by uncle mark we call
it uncle marks Park Mark Jackson he
lives in Calabasas so the kids love to
go as we call it - uncle marks Park to
shoot hoops so we always call mark and
the local kids and we meet up in
Calabasas at play at this Park well why
don't you if you see Drake you invite
Drake and then all go I'll guard Drake
and then you know we'll play it like no
he doesn't you saw him in Midnight
Madness at the Kentucky a couple years
ago he couldn't make a layup well he's
gonna be really nervous when he sees me
on the floor I'm not afraid and it's
frayed and if you tell though you and I
so we tell Drake to get since I'm
retired and Katy lives out here no no he
can't fkg Mark Jackson yeah yeah I want
you back you and I it'll be you like
that yeah you and me against Drake and
Mark Jackson done deal tall it's Drake
is Eve five eight five nine or zero
he's pushing six Oh is he all right so I
can push him up oh yeah Oh trust me
Mouse in the house I'm gonna that's what
I do I go into the lab I'm gonna go to
work on Drake there I want to make him
write a song about me we're talking to
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer he's
only called Sixers bucks Thursday night
Sixers are a mess right now Reggie can
can the can the Sixers continue to be a
good team or try to be a good team with
Ben Simmons and Joe LM beat can they
complement each other coming into the
season I felt that they had one of the
stronger you know starting five with
Josh Richardson Tobias Harris Ben
Simmons Joel embiid I wouldn't
necessarily say there's a chemistry
issue but the injury to embiid has hurt
them and now he's back you know playing
and now they're trying to integrate him
to me I don't think he gets enough
touches you know there's places where I
read that they're thinking it has
crossed Elton Brand mind of them trading
Ben Simmons so is that messing up the
psyche of a young player who's an
all-star and you know it's supposed to
be the face you know of the franchise
along with Joelle and beed you know I
mentioned this earlier they need more
shooting but who do you give up you know
I like the rookie
mattias ty Bowl out of Washington yeah
but their bench
there's not a lot there so if they could
find more shooting somewhere I'm sure
that would help but you know Josh
Richardson has been out with a hamstring
injury for the last two two and a half
weeks not sure when he's coming back but
they've been filling consistent you know
you know Tobias Harris has been up and
down and again you know we talked about
embiid this dish he should be the best
center in the game to me him applying
himself he he always looks like he's out
of shape right because he's always hurt
so he can't practice and it's got to
make it tough you know for that coaching
staff you know when your best player is
out on the floor you know to practice
yeah I'm gonna leave you with this Mark
Cuban said he'd support the NBA logo
change to honor Kobe
what do you think about them I can see
that I jump on board on I think there's
probably a lot of people that are
thinking that MJ should be the logo like
you can't go wrong you know Jerry West
has been a fantastic ambassador for our
game I think that was evident in his
words and how he felt for Kobe on our
show that Tuesday night but you know I
don't know about changing it while you
still have a man that's alive and still
a part of our game and still works in
the game in Jerry West but I would have
zero problems with a Kobe Bryant and a
while we float them well we have
multiple you know symbols right why
can't we have MJ and Kobe and Jerry West
right I don't know it feels like it you
know it needs to be one I mean I know
yeah and you know Jerry West would be
fine with letting Kobe be that logo
because nobody ever asked Jerry about
being a logo he just became the logo and
I don't think he'd have a problem if
Kobe became that logo I have no problem
with it either
yeah that's a tough call again you still
have a guy out there in incycle Jordan
who people consider the greatest as well
- yeah I think Mike's okay I think
Mike's okay he's got his own logo he
makes it a whole lot more money
[Laughter]
have fun on Thursday night Sixers Bucks
on TNT with Kevin Hartman Thank You reg
again if I see Dre yep I can throw down
the SmackDown challenge is that what
you're telling me on so everyone is
clear here I'll do that and then I'll
rap battle with him after that
[Music]
that's the Reggie Aloysius Miller jr.
that they're form or Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]